it might just be a way for you to leave
the country but Canadian passports are
holding their value on the world stage
Henley and partners released its list of
the most powerful passports and for
another year Canada is in the top 10
we've been compiling the data for about
19 years uh we were the creators of this
index that's used as a global reference
ranking all all the countries that have
Visa free or visa on arrival and Canada
has been ranked seventh Henley and
partners use official data from the
International Air transport Association
to build the
[Music]
list it's based on how many destinations
a traveler can visit without a Visa six
tied for first place with four
Continental European countries as well
as Japan and Singapore holding their top
spots from last year the United Kingdom
landed in fourth with 191 locations
while Canada and the US are in the
seventh position with 188 I think that
that that speaks to a desire hopefully
of our government to continue to make it
easier and easier easier for Canadian
citizens
to freely travel but access can be
lost Canadians saw it firsthand last
year after India banned visas to
passport holders experts say anas's
relationships with governments are vital
to how far a Canadian passport can take
someone it's pretty tough to walk that
line and my own view is we have to be
prepared to stand up for a national
interests even at the risk of some
inconvenience to members of gasp
communities at the start of 2023 Canada
was ranked in the eighth position with
Visa free access to 186 Nations Kyle
Benning Global News